i am a big fan of this man's work um i
don't know if he's ever been on this
show before in our six years
uh loved him uh in mr show with bob and
david way back in the day that was
before
arrested development and um also in
goliath
where uh he played a far different
character than the one that he did in uh
other shows that included also the ben
stiller show and his new movie the dark
divide
available now on vod digital and blu-ray
and dvd platforms wherever you can get
that
uh the highly talented david cross back
here on the rich island oh well we're
here on the rich
how are you david uh i'm good and uh
you know it's interesting as you were uh
doing that intro
yes sir right before you were saying i
don't know if he's been on the show i
was
actually sitting here thinking have i
been on this show before
i don't think so i don't know i usually
do have a a good recollection of that
sort of thing but i've wanted you on for
quite some time because everything that
i just read i
you are hilarious man uh and you are
excellent at what you do so i'm glad
that you're
well thank you you are most welcome um
you're from
atlanta is that where you're from
originally yeah are you okay yeah
so is that is that the part of the
country that you associate yourself with
or
or what i mean did you spend much time
there when you're in atlanta
um well uh i think all my family
well most of my family's still down
there um so i'm there quite a bit but
now that i have a
uh daughter we're down there
i mean you know outside of covet stuff
we're right there about
four or five times a year pretty much so
the reason why i ask is just basically
also
do you have any sports teams from there
david did you grow up any atlanta sports
fan in any way shape
yeah unfortunately yes um yeah
uh i was i said there was i am
a braves fan um went to
tons of braves games because they when
they sucked it was very cheap
i remember there was a you know one of
those quarter car wash
chains called national pride car wash
and they would have coupons
that would allow you to get to into the
game for like a couple bucks
so my friends and i would go to those
games it wouldn't cost much
and then also the atlanta flames
sucked for a long time as well and uh
um so we'd get into those games fairly
cheaply
and um and then uh
unfortunately a falcons fan too so well
i was at the world series
win that game i've been to a lot of race
games over the years but i was actually
at the
you know the last game in the old uh
stadium county stadium
the old fulton county stadium back in
the day so uh if i had a guest then
uh was like dale murphy your guy growing
up
is that is that i love i love dale
murphy but i was also
a red sox fan um i just i really like
the red sox
and then i moved to boston from atlanta
and you know went to tons of games at
fenway which is just a completely
different
and better experience yes um and
i was a big dwight evans fan um
but you know i i was yeah definitely
dale murphy was
was my guy but all you know a lot of
those
um those earlier teams that have named
characters like i've done
movies and tv shows and i usually have
some old braves characters in there
i took i did a movie called hits and i
had two cops
uh were uh lemke and blauser
her name's the cops
and i got those sprinkled though
throughout a lot of my work over the
yeah
i mean did you ever hear from sid bream
and say what gives i mean did you ever
i remember exactly where i was when the
when the slide happened
i was at a bar in new york city and and
i
yeah i just remember the you know
hanging on to the
watching the game in a in a bar and and
banging my
foot pretty bad on the stool the little
you know the rail of the stool
yeah as i was like jumping up and down
and um
got caught in there yeah well i i also
remember uh one of the biggest moments i
guess in atlanta flames history was when
jim craig
if i'm not mistaken afterwards yeah you
know
the gold medal where he he went between
the pipes for the atlanta
flames i haven't heard that yeah and it
was a big it was about as
big a promotional push because i
remember coca-cola was behind it because
they're local
you know and uh um that was a big deal
and then i think they were gone within
two years i want to say
they've moved to calgary with any with
it within a year or two years of his
signing i remember but i did
catch a um slap shot
that went up and hit the um because we
used to buy her tickets there was nobody
there so he'd buy the cheapest tickets
and then he just moved down and
you know being like the the third row
behind the goal
and um and there was uh
eric vale i remember it was eric bale
who hit the slap shot
it went off the glass and just went
spinning uh
and i just instinctively
you know jumped up and put my hand up
and it hurt like a mug i don't know if
you're allowed to swear but no
no no it's okay it is a family show
exactly but
uh a mother a mother friendly a mother a
mother clucker hurt like a mother
clucker
yes uh like you know and i was probably
like
i don't know would that have been like
12
or something like that amazing uh 13 and
uh
yeah just damaged my little hand but it
was pretty cool david cross here uh on
the rich eisen show let's uh
before we get into uh i i go down memory
lane a little bit with uh
with with some of my celebrity guests
and and ask them in celebrity true or
false stuff that i've seen in
articles and quotes if they're true or
not before we get to that let's talk
about the dark divide
uh you play uh the dr robert
pyle uh in this film yeah real guy which
is a real guy
walk me through this and why you did
this and how you got involved in this
this uh this fair sir what do you got
for me
um so it's uh it's a
true true-ish story it's uh it really
takes from a bunch of his books but it's
um
a guy who the kind of mild-mannered
uh uh lepidopterous
kind of bookish kind of guy very
introverted
um who through these
extenuating circumstances involving his
deceased
wife ends up going on this journey
through uh the dark divide which is the
the nickname of the
gifford gifford pinchot national forest
out in the pacific northwest it's like
the largest
uncharted wild bit of land in the
lower 48 states left and um
this is back in 1995 and he's
just in way over his head he doesn't
know what he's doing he's uh
very naive about what he's about to
undertake and
you know it's one of those kind of
stories and movies
where you know he goes in he starts his
journey he starts one way and through
all the
this arduous journey he goes on
you know near-death experiences and all
kinds of things that happen and the
people he meet
meets uh ends up a completely different
person at the end
you know and he went in there thinking
he was going to be gone for
a little under a month and he was lost
all track
time and he was actually almost six
weeks in there and just
it was uh and i rarely get offered that
kind of
opportunity and uh i really like the
story and i like to
i like the idea of being in my underwear
a lot you know on screen
and uh and you're welcome you're welcome
for that yes
um and uh
and so and then once i met with the
writer and director
to uh which is the same person tom
putnam uh wrote
wrote and directed it and and just when
i messed with him because if you're
gonna do something because it was very
low budget really brutal tough
i mean we shot in a lot of the real
locations and you know there's no
electricity there's no you can't there's
no
roads at a certain point you just park
to drive as far as you can then you get
out and you
plug all this gear with a skeleton crew
a new you know the interior of these
crazy woods and uh you know there's no
internet
no electricity no cell phone service
nothing like that and
you know it was a really difficult shoot
so i wanted to make sure i
you know jived with him and i i did and
then i was like yeah let's do it
and um and it's again uh available now
on vod digital
and blu-ray slash dvd platforms plus
let's be honest uh
odenkirk can't have all the serious
roles where he's going through
great physical harm and actually doing
this right you got to you got to stay
tuned
you got to keep up with him right now
you know yeah exactly we're
we're dueling i'm racing up the charts
yes you are
catching butterflies um so in in the
dark divide it's it's a great movie
everyone should go check it out um if
you don't mind uh
endeavoring a little celebrity true or
false here on the rich eisen show i
greatly appreciate it david cross
okay would you absolutely here we go we
even have a drop for it go for it please
celebrity true or false you can't handle
the truth
oh boy very good it's very dramatic
setting up a celebrity true or false
with david cross again these are items
that we have uh captured from articles
that have been written about you
or uh are on the internet you got to
tell us if it's true or false
uh first item uh quote uh you am i
guessing or am i
no you're confirming you're confirming
or saying this is true or false
okay this is not okay okay okay you're
confirming for us uh
according to one article you have quote
no qualms whatsoever unquote about
taking your clothes off
for any reason is that true or false
david cross
uh truish um the reason should be good
but it really depends on how much i've
been drinking
okay so it really depends on the actual
alcohol intake
but professionally this is something
that you're you're open to is what
you're saying oh
oh yeah i mean uh mr show there's uh
you know if we got if he got rid of that
video digital scrambler thing i'm sure
he'd be seeing them
get quite an eye load bob
from the two of you back in the day that
that was so much fun
that was was there ever something that
you did that uh on mr show
uh with bob and david that you were told
you could not do
and that had to be hit on the cunningham
floor literally one
literally in four years there was one
thing and that is and it's uh
there's a i can't remember the thing but
it's like a flashback it's in the
opening there's a flashback
where i'm playing my
dad or yeah and and marilyn rice cub is
the mom and there's a baby which is
supposed to be me which is a plastic
doll clearly a plastic doll
yes and i say something about the baby
and
the mom mary lynn
slams the baby down the ground goes f
that's this baby
and that was the one thing that said
yeah we don't really don't want you to
do that we're like oh okay
so we had to find a different way
okay so other than that it was all it's
all good ready to go on mr show yeah
okay very good next one uh for you
you're originally approached to play
buster bluth in arrested development but
you chose tobias instead is that true
uh yeah that was they had sent me uh
uh actually they wanted me to look at
job and buster and job i had no
reading on at all i didn't understand it
and buster seemed really fun but tobias
was
in there and i just immediately
gravitated to
that character and i also knew
immediately how i wanted to play him
uh so i lobbied for that and they were
like fine
is he based on anybody that you have met
before who's tobias
where you said you know you know he's
he's he the way i pitched him was
um like a half
a a mash up an amalgamation of
a like east coast dick band
uh what's the guy's name dick habit like
east coast
turtleneck wearing dick habit type of uh
intellectual or pseudo-intellectual in
his case uh
meets a kind of marin county
touchy feely uh cable sweater
uh kind of like you know
uh a therapist who makes up uh his
his own brand of therapy and just calls
himself a therapist you know
like a mix of those two types of people
what's your favorite scene from arrested
development david cross
which is your favorite oh come on come
on i know how to do it
richard richard david come on
i don't i don't i don't i mean you know
i could say something now and it'll
change in 10 minutes if i remember
another one
but i mean i i remember
having i remember rarely laughing as
hard as i ever
have there's a thing with a it's like a
flashback to a party or something and
bust uh buster tony hale's playing the
piano we're in the we're in the
the uh lucille's living room the
penthouse
and then i think job is on
laying on the table dining room table
and
i can't remember what michael's doing
and i'm dancing
in my i'm laughing thinking about it now
in my
you know uh never nude shorts and just
that was also like the end of a long day
it was like hour 13 and we were all
loopy and just doing that and uh and i
know for a fact that
when you see will arnett laughing well
and jason laughing in the background
that's them laughing
for real they couldn't stop laughing i
was about to say who's the one that was
the easiest to break up
on the set like would would just
crack that's a good question um
wow maybe maybe me i don't know
jason's a pro i mean he's he's pretty
great i'd say
will or me you know would be one of the
two of us
so it's funny you said that tony was
really good at i mean
solid he's done staying that way yeah
because it's funny so will had a better
read of the job character
than you did and so everyone wound up in
the right spots
in that oh yeah i mean once i and then
once i saw will in it i
i was like of course that i never that
didn't even occur to me
and i just can't imagine uh
it's one of those rare casts where i
just can't imagine anybody
else playing those roles you know
right like i and uh
yeah once because i never met will
before
um or even knew of them but when i
was watching it all happen when we were
shooting the pilot i was like oh god of
course
this guy's great perfect perfect it
certainly is david cross the dark divide
where everybody
can check it out on vod digital and
blu-ray slash dvd platforms right now
thanks for the call david
appreciate it i meant what i said i'm a
big fan and i and i hope uh we get to
chat a little bit more go down more of
your atlanta sports memory lane next
time too thank you
well thanks man and i want to thank you
for all you're helping me with all my
fantasy baseball uh decisions over the
last
decades i had no idea the pressure was
on so
um yeah have you won a championship
based on my on my knowledge i have
okay yes yes i have fantastic um
i didn't i didn't see a play i didn't
see my playoff share
david i didn't get that but i'll just
yeah no it should be check your check
your paypal and
uh that should be in there very good
thank you david i will do that in the
commercial break thanks for the call
david i appreciate it you take care
all right absolutely thank you that's
david cross at david cross on
twitter davidcrossofficial on instagram